bonjour à tous c'est un jour un fossile
et aujourd'hui on va parler de l'enfant
de tongs
voici l'enfant de tongs
voici l'original du fossile de l'enfant
de tang probablement l'un des fossiles
les plus importants au monde parce qu'il
s'agit du tout premier australopithèques
qui ait jamais été découvert alors
beaucoup de gens pensent qu'il s'agit de
lucic l'uci et le premier
australopithèques qui a été découvert
mais non en fait c'est l'enfant de tongs
l'uci a été découvert dans les années 70
alors que l'enfant de tang lui il a été
découvert dans les années 20 en 1924
donc l'enfant de tang c'est le plus
vieil australopithèque et ça ça veut
dire que à chaque fois que quelqu un qu
un chercheur découvre une nouvelle
espèce d'hominidé et qu'ils veulent
appeler australopithecus et bien il doit
venir ici dans les collections de
l'université du vibrateur secondes pour
étudier l'enfant de tanguay comparer sa
nouvelle espèce et voir si elle est
suffisamment similaires à l'enfant de
tang pour être pour être appelé
australopithecus donc ça et c'est ça qui
fait que l'enfant de tang et le fossile
le plus important c'est lolo type
d'australopithecus pour ceux qui savent
qu'ils connaissent la terminologie c'est
le spécimen de référence des
australopithèques donc ça ça fait de
l'enfant tang l'un des fossiles les plus
précieux du monde et donc c'est pour ça
qu'il ait gardé ici à l'université de
visiteurs se rendent dans ce qu'on
appelle la volt c'est à dire le coffre
fort alors je vais vous montrer la deux
la porte la porte du coffre-fort voilà
donc vous pouvez voir que c'est de la
bonne épaisseur de portes 1 voilà c'est
une véritable c'est un véritable
coffre-fort en fait c'est ici on a
toutes les collections à l'intérieur du
coffre fort on a toutes les collections
de comparaison d'hominidés de
l'université de vie de bathurst round
donc et c'est l'une des plus importantes
collections d'hominidés fossiles et
modernes du monde
donc cet enfant de tang il est
incroyable sa préservation aller assez
incroyable donc vous pouvez voir donc
déjà il a une jolie petite phase mais il
a aussi une mâchoire et alors si vous
regardez la mâchoire de plus près est-ce
que je vais arriver à filmer ça
correctement voilà je ne sais pas si
vous arrivez à avoir mais la mâchoire
elle est assez impressionnante les dents
sont d'une fraîcheur incroyable on a
l'impression en fait qu'il est qu'il
vient juste de mourir quoi tellement les
dans son bel donc l'enfant de temps qui
s'appelle l'enfant de tanks pour deux
raisons déjà il s'appelle tangue parce
que en fait il vient d'une ville qui
s'appelle tang
il a été découvert alors que alors qu'on
exploiter une mine de phosphate ou de
calcite je ne sais plus en tout cas il a
été découvert dans une mine donc on a
fait exploser à bloc et dans ce bloc il
y avait l'enfant de temps que vous lui
montrerez juste après et il s'appelle
l'enfant de tang justement à cause de
ses dents parce qu'en fait si vous
pouvez voir mais vous avez
vous n'avez pas dedans enfin vous n'avez
qu'une seule d'un adulte et c'est la
dernière molaires si vous comptez le
nombre de dents en fait il n'a pas
toutes ses dents quoi là c'est juste ça
ce que vous voyez ce sont des dents de
lait à part la dernière molaires qui est
en fait la première molaire qui est en
train de sortir
voilà je peux vous montrer sur un sur un
moulage dont leurs formes tang sa
dentition donc voilà un moulage du crâne
donc
d'ailleurs ça me permet de vous montrer
un truc c'est que les moulages se sont
pas défaut il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent vrai dans les musées les gens
mettent des faux noms les faux les
moulages se sont pas des faux les
moulages ce sont des copies conformes à
l'original
regardez la comparaison regardez la
comparaison voilà ça c'est le moulage ça
c'est l'original donc vous voyez que
quand même quand même ils se ressemblent
un bon bah là évidemment il ya la
différence d'échelle parce que ma main
peut pas passer au travers de la vitre
mais évidemment que que les moulages
sont faits pour être fidèle à l'original
et donc regarder sa dentition voilà vous
voyez ici les incisives de l'est qui
sont très très petit
vous voyez les canines la canine de
l'est aussi
les deux premières les deux prémolaires
et voici donc la seule dans adultes de
l'enfant de tang qui est donc une
molaire c'est là donc c'est la dernière
dent de la rangée mais c'est la première
molaire à sortir donc voilà ça c'est un
moulage un moulage c'est une copie
parfaite enfin du moins la meilleure
possible du spécimen original et alors
comment on fait la différence entre une
copie est un original et bien dans le
cas de l'enfant de temps que c'est très
simple donc vous avez alors l'enfant de
temps voici la copie du moulage
endocriniens le moulage en doc rania
c'est le moulage de la cavité crânienne
donc c'est le moulage en fait de la
cavité où il y avait le cerveau c'est
pas le cerveau lui même attention c'est
pas le cerveau fossilisé c'est la boîte
crânienne en fait c'est le moulage de la
boîte crânienne mais n'empêche que ça
préserve des détails magnifique comme
par exemple vous voyez ici les vaisseaux
sanguins on voit très très bien les
vaisseaux sanguins et ça c'est juste un
moulage c'est juste un moulage et on
arrive à voir les vaisseaux sanguins
dessus et sur l'original c'est pareil
bon alors là avec la caméra je sais pas
si la résolution de la caméra est
suffisante mais normalement vous devez
pouvoir voir les vaisseaux sanguins
et donc la différence entre le moulage
est le vrai sur le temps que j'aille là
est très facile à faire donc voici
l'autre côté du moulage en os crânien
sur le moulage et voici l'autre côté de
l'endocrâne sur le l'original et vous
pouvez voir il ya des magnifiques
cristaux de calcite en fait donc c'est
très très beau alors ça ça brille pas
autant sur la caméra que ça ne devrait
j'essaie de bouger pour vous voyez un
petit peu la brillance de ces cristaux
de calcite donc c'est voilà ça c'est la
différence entre un original et un
moulage donc voilà ne laissait plus
jamais personne vous dire que dans les
musées ce sont des faux noms ce sont des
ce sont des copies conformes à
l'original mais bon bah évidemment on
peut pas être fidèle à 100% on peut pas
recréer le brillant du cristal quoi non
plus mais mais voilà il ya plusieurs
choses intéressantes à savoir sur
l'enfant de tang
la première c'est que c'est que déjà il
s est un fossile dont qui a été
découvert en 1924 donc il est très très
usés il est très très usés et notamment
ses incisives ses incisives elles ont
perdu à force d'être mesurés avec un
pied à coulisse en fait ses incisives
ont été abîmés et elles ont perdu je
crois presque 1 mm de largeur et ça
c'est assez triste mais c'est assez
triste mais bon c'est comme ça quoi les
fossiles sont là pour être étudiés quoi
et du coup maintenant il ya une
politique de protection de l'enfant de
tang c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il est
dans cette boîte
1 c'est pas pour empêcher les gens de le
voir ou quoi que ce soit c'est juste
pour le protéger et pour que les gens y
réfléchissent à deux fois avant de
mettre leurs gros doigts tout seul
dessus et j'ai vraiment eu de la chance
parce que je fais partie des quelques
privilégiés qui ont eu la possibilité de
toucher l'enfant de temps que je vous
affiche une photo la de moi en train de
de faire le kéké à côté de l'enfant de
tang
et j'étais vraiment enfin je veux dire
c'est vraiment un instant assez
incroyable de toucher ce fossile parce
que c'est c'est pas seulement de la
préhistoire quoi c'est de l'histoire
c'est c'est magnifique de pouvoir
étudier un spécimen comme ça quoi
et d'ailleurs en sortant de là une fois
que j'ai fini mon travail je suis allé
voir les collègues en leur disant tu
vois mais ma tu vois même assez de la
poussière de l'enfant de tang qui assure
mes doigts bon c'est peut-être juste de
la poussière tout court mais moi voilà
c'était un grand moment pour moi
et cet enfant de tanguy les aussi
spécial parce que c'est la première fois
aussi qu'on a pu voir à quoi ressemblait
le cerveau de nos ancêtres les
australopithèques donc un cerveau qui
est qui à peu près de la taille de celui
d'un chimpanzé quoi donc on sait pas
quel sexe
de quel sexe et l enfant de tang par
contre par contre on a une bonne idée de
comment il est mort donc des gens ont
scanné le crâne et ils ont pu voir le
fond des orbites alors le fond des
orbites
il n'est pas visible là puisque vous
voyez il n'a pas été préparée il ya
encore de la terre dans le fond des
orbites
mais ils ont pu voir le fond d orbite
grâce aux ct scan est en fait ils ont vu
qu'il y avait des traces de serre daigle
au fond des orbites ce donc ce pauvre
enfant de temps qu'en fait il s'est fait
attraper je vais vous montrer donc son
crâne
en fait si vous regardez sur le moulage
il s'est fait attraper par un aigle
comme ça comme cela avec les cerfs qui
lui rentrer dans les yeux mais façon
hardcore quoi donc
pauvre petit enfant de temps quoi il a
morflé
il a morflé il a dû souffrir si vous
imaginez vous faire trimballer en l'air
la com ça vous faire trimballer en l'air
comme ça par un aigle
alors que vous avez les serres dans les
yeux ça a dû être les dernières les
derniers instants de sa vie en duel
extrêmement douloureux et je ne les
envie pas pour ça et un autre truc qui
enfin un dernier truc qui est vraiment
super cool à propos de l'enfant de temps
que c'est la façon dont il a été trouvé
donc je vous ai dit qu'ils avaient été
trouvés justement dans une mine
donc il a été en fait il s'est fait
exploser dans une mine
c'est carrément ça qui s'est passé ça se
trouve il y avait plus de l'enfant de
temps que juste le crâne et le moulage
endocrânienne mais le reste a dû se
faire exploser
et en fait le seul truc qu'on a retrouvé
de l'enfant de tang basse et ça c'est un
bloc donc ça c'est le moulage du bloc
dans lequel se trouvaient de l'enfant de
tang quand il a été découvert donc ils
ont quand même eu la présence d'esprit
de faire un moulage du bloc avant de
préparer le spécimen et ans que l'enfant
de temps que c'est ça c'est ça alors ça
ressemble à rien vu comme ça mais mais
c'est l'enfant de tang qui est là alors
si j'arrive à positionner ça comme il
faut pour pouvoir vous le comparez le
problème c'est que j'ai qu'une main vu
que je tiens le téléphone voilà donc la
voyez ça c'est l'enfant de tanguay en
fait c'est pas là c'est pas le visage
que vous voyez voilà le visage de
l'enfant de tang est valide
voilà l'autre côté de l'enfant de tang
est en fait ce que vous voyez là voilà
c'est la même chose donc c'est pas le
visage c'est l'arrière du visage dans ce
qu'il ya d'intéressant c'est que sur
cette arrière du visage mais là on voit
le fond de la cavité des yeux donc ça
c'est ça c'est le fond des orbites vu
par derrière en fait vu par l'intérieur
de la boîte crânienne donc là vous aviez
les lobes frontaux du cerveau
et ça ce sont les yeux ça c'est le nez
ça ce sont les deux troncs les deux
trous du des naseaux et là vous aviez
les dents la justice'' vous avez une les
dents et donc rien qu'en voyant ça en
fait
raymonde art qui est la personne qui a
étudié l'enfant de temps qu'en 1924 et
bien il a su quoi ce qu'il regardait
tout simplement parce que les seuls
animaux qui ont le fond des yeux
complètement fermée comme ça eh ben ce
sont les primates il ya que les primates
qui ont le fond des yeux fermés de cette
façon donc on sait déjà rien qu'en
regardant leurs fonds de tangue comme ça
qu'on a affaire à un primate
et quand on regarde par là on voit le la
mâchoire inférieure regarder ça c'est la
mâchoire je voulais dessiner avec le
doigt comme ça voyez lie à la mâchoire
inférieure et on voit même la cavité
pulpaire la cavité des dents qui a été
cassée ici donc ça c'est la mâchoire
inférieure de l'enfant de tang et vous
pouvez voir que cette mâchoire elle
n'est pas carré elle est arrondi
et ça c'est un caractère domini n'ai
donc rien qu'en regardant ce truc qui a
l'air de rien bad
raymonde art il a été capable de dire ah
la vache c'est un primate
oh la vache et un hominidé et c'est
comme ça que raymonde art a découvert le
premier australopithecus et
occasionnellement le premier le premier
homininés en afrique est le plus ancien
de son époque et donc le thang child en
fait c'est le fossile qui a réécrit
l'histoire de l'évolution humaine avant
la découverte du thon chad
on ne connaissait que néandertal et
l'homo erectus et pas n'importe lequel
homo erectus l'homme de l'homme de java
donc on avait découvert des homininés
fossiles que en asie en europe et du
coup on pensait qu'il ya que les
hominidés étaient originaires d'asie et
d'europe
il y avait que charles darwin qui à
l'époque avait éventuellement spéculer
qui avait possiblement une origine
africaine mais le registre fossile de
son époque ne le soutenait pas du tout
et en fait c'est le ton child qui en
étant à la fois plus primitifs comeau
erectus et que l'homme de néandertal et
en étant découverts en afrique et bien a
démontré pour la première fois que les
êtres humains étaient originaires
d'afrique
donc voilà ça c'est le fossile qui a
changé l'histoire de l'homme à tout
jamais et qui a placé l'origine humaine
en afrique
voilà c'était un jour un fossile je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi je vous dis à
très bientôt
ciao